Hello, everybody. This is Dr. Kevin Cutters and another podcast is going to be a good one today with I'm here with Lloyd Burrell from ElectricSense.com.
We really recommend that you go to his website. He has a ton of information.
The dangers of EMFs and particularly what we're going to talk about today is 5G, the dangers of 5G that's coming out.
There's a little background in Lloyd's life. He states this on his website. One day in 2002, he answered his cell phone and soon after developed highly debilitating symptoms when using all types of electromagnetic devices.
Some people listening to that can relate to that. Devices in his home and his workplace. Lloyd has now made his life's mission to raise awareness about the dangers of EMF fields and share the remarkable discoveries that is made on his quest to recover his health.
Well, he realized that was a major cause for it. For over 10 years, Lloyd has been speaking at online events, podcasts, radio shows, and hosts own by monthly EMF health podcast highly recommend you listen to that.
We are on his website. He's the author of the e-book, long-term EMF protection and creator of the EMF health summit and founder of the website that we spoke about electricsense.com.
Lloyd, so happy to have you here and to talk about it. Really, I want to concentrate this interview on 5G. A lot of people don't really understand it.
I certainly don't fully understand it. There's a lot being hidden from the general public. I think you would state that. So can you explain what 5G is and why it can be dangerous to the human.
The starting point of this conversation, I feel, is that we're despite what we might have heard in mainstream media and in accepted medical circles is that we are essentially electromagnetic beings.
We are energy beings. When you've got a problem with your heart, you go for an ECG measure electrical activity. When you have a problem with your brain, you go for an EEG measure the electrical activity of your brain.
We know most people know that nerves are communicating via electrical pulses. Some people know that our cell membranes have a potential. This is actually what is the determining characteristic between life or death is the cell membrane potential.
So it's an electrical potential. So we are very clearly electromagnetic beings. So this is where 5G, which is the next form of wireless technology, fits into this conversation is because we're up in the stakes in terms of our exposure.
And we have exposure to these electromagnetic fields. And that's what we're really talking about, particularly with 5G what we're talking actually talking about very specifically, which again is not being said is radio frequency microwave radiation and these devices which we're using wireless devices are emitting receiving radio frequency microwave radiation.
And so that comes sometimes can come as a surprise to people when they hear that because the industry doesn't use those terms, obviously it uses while it just uses wireless it uses terms like Bluetooth terms like smart uses really all kinds of terms except really the terms that best describe it.
And already when we when we use was like radiation, then we begin to understand well, we begin to think when somebody says radiation to you in connection with your health, then already you're asking us self questions hang on a minute. So actually when I'm using these devices that I'm being exposed to radiation, yes, you are.
And what you mean radiation like nuclear radiation like Fukushima like Chernobyl.
Kind of but not quite because that's slightly different that's a different category of radiations what we call ionizing radiation.
And what we're talking about here is non ionizing radiation and there's a lot of science pointing to the fact that this the end result of this non ionizing radiation which the telecoms industry in which even our governments are saying is basically safe that it's only the thermal effects which count and I'm sorry it is a bit technical bit of a technical subject straight in here but
what the science is saying is that the end result of these exposures from all these devices which we're using the cell phones and the Wi-Fi and the Bluetooth and the smart devices etc is the same as this ionizing radiation.
And so that's what's important and that's also 5G is the next evolution in this this is where we're going whether we like it or not into this new world of higher connectivity of greater download speeds between 10 and 100 times faster than 4G supposedly.
That remains to be seen whether that is actually because there's a lot of hype around this but actually whether that is possible I'm not entirely sure that that is possible anywhere on the planet is yeah and so yeah there is a lot of hype around this and so 5G is quite simply the next evolution in this.
You're saying that 5G is equivalent to microwave radiation everything's a microwave you think of your microwave oven and your kitchen that is using a certain type of radiation to heat food much faster than you know a convection oven or something.
And those waves are hopefully blocked by the wall of your microwaves so that they're not being exposed to you know one could measure the waves coming out of your microwave with an EMF reader and show that microwave ovens are dangerous but you only have those on for a minute heat your food when you're near a 5G tower you're being exposed to those 247.
Well so firstly with regards when I say microwave yes I mean microwave like microwave ovens so microwave ovens operate at 2.4 gigahertz and that is actually the same frequency as what most Wi-Fi modem routers operate at the some higher frequencies being used now in the 5 and 10 gigahertz range.
But yes when we say so when we say gigahertz that means billions of cycles a second so yeah that's the first strange thing which we can say well how can we be using the same frequencies for Wi-Fi has been used in a microwave oven it's not exactly the same characteristics there's more to it than that it's more complex radiation which we're using for communication because it has data.
So it's made onto it as well and that which is not a point in its favor at all but yes so it's microwave and we're talking about frequency and whenever we're talking about EMF we're talking about frequency and wavelength and these are connected and the higher the frequency the lower the wavelength and vice versa.
So yes it's about microwave radiation very clearly that's what 5G means and it's 5G in internet of things and just to be clear so there's a lot of talk about 5G and in a way I'm kind of glad that we are talking about it even if it's not in the right way but there is a kind of an obsession in some quarters about 5G and about how dangerous it is
but the real dangers are all these MS which we're being exposed to so it's not just about 5G because 5G is just another layer, 5G is just another layer of electrosmog so we're surrounded by these man-made frequencies both wireless and wired and let's not forget that either you know because our home's offices schools have wireless wiring which are emitting electric fields, magnetic fields and dirty.
We're talking about 5G and there are dangers associated with 5B but it's it's all these electromagnetic fields which are impacting our health and that's what the science is saying.
Well and I agree we can actually measure someone's what's called their phase angle which is a measurement of the electrical impulse of their cell membranes and if a person's phase angle decreases they don't have that healthy electrical impulse of their cell membrane you know they're in the process of dying.
There's much published data about that it's not disputable it's not alternative it is standard medicine and when you're talking about EMF fields that are dangerous to the human body they affect that impulse of your cell membranes and you're talking about this cumulative effect of dirty electricity electrical fields that are around us high wires that are around us
people will they go I don't have a cell phone or I don't use my cell phone very often so that I'd protect it but really you're not I mean unless you're going to move somewhere where there is you know is there any place on the planet you can move to be protected maybe some places that are safer than others out of cities but we're all being affected by this.
Yes, we are all being affected by this and we have been affected by for quite a long time now really since the the evolution of of wireless by Marconi back in the 1930s we've been if you look back at the studies then we have we have certain evidence which is linking these exposures to difficult to how it's done.
It's affecting the B population the bird population and then when radar was introduced we have more science on that also this how these radar operators were being notably how they were getting cataracts on their eyes and so on and there's researchers that have worked on that and notably Milton Zarrett back in the 1950s he started some research on that
and he was told to not dig any deeper if he wants to keep his job basically and there's a number of cases where that's that's happened over the years so yeah this is this is 5g is new but the mf's is not new it's been around for a long time and it's been impacting our health for a long time but what is new with the 5g is is that we're moving into these higher frequency bands because it's not going to be good.
The existing frequency bands are saturated so most cell phones work in one to two gigahertz range something like that and most of the existing consumer bands are sub six gigahertz and now we're going beyond that 10 gigahertz 20 gigahertz even 80 100 gigahertz in different parts of the world.
We have used this technology has been used before but it's been used for in war zones in for crowd control these very high frequencies and so what we're doing now is we're deploying these very high frequencies which we don't exactly know what this is going to do for 24 7 exposure but we're beaming down these frequencies from space via satellites
over 100,000 satellites have been put into space by companies like SpaceX to do to beam down this 5g so that we can get this as you say this 5g anywhere on the planet and then we've got these small cells in urban areas so these small antennas for the 5g and the fire and what's also happening with the 5g is we we're bringing we're having densification of the 4g as well which is a previous generation
which you know who knows what's worth so 5g or the 4g the difference between the 5g and the 4g the 5g technology is like an on demand technology so if you don't have a 5g phone then you're not pulling it into your home whereas the 4g cell towers are emitting this radiation 24 7 and it's at these lower frequencies which has more penetrative power because we're the higher we go in the frequency the less the penetrative power
and so that's why they're having to have only small cells what the industry calls small cells these small antennas everywhere every third or fourth house in certain urban areas.
When people the question people have with 5g is that okay so I live in you know in urban area and I see a 5g tower at the end of my block but I don't have a 5g cell phone so am I protected?
So here's the thing is with what we need to focus on is not the 5g it's the emf's we need to look at all the emf's and you're speaking to a person who got very sick way before 5g came along from using a cell phone cell phone exposures and that just came on out the blue and this is what I share now is what I learned from this experience and it's about dealing with all these exposures
because and this and I've been talking with building apologies scientists research etc for a long time now about these different issues and what we're finding is particularly from emf consultants building apologies so going into people's homes who are complaining about 5g is that their homes are full of radiation of emf's from other devices nothing to do with the 5g
and the 5g is an additional issue but it's for many it's not the most important issue the most important issue is what's going on in your home and there's a reason for that is because the way emf's work the closer you are to the device for instance if you have a cell phone and so I have a cell phone since about three weeks I've been 19 years without a cell phone and I've got a cell phone now
because you can't do it a lot now online without a cell phone you know to bank security and things like that my cell phone is the other end of the corridor switched off it's not a problem but if I bring the cell phone in here and I switch it on take it off airplane mode then it's a problem so the thing to remember with these emf's is distance is your friend
and so and that's because these emf's work in an exponential manner so just by gaining a small distance between your device your exponentially reducing your exposure
and so that means if you think about that the other way around that means everything you have in your home that is electrical is a potential source of emf
and given that we are moving into this smart world which goes with the 5G, 5G, IoT, Internet of Things so it's all the smart systems connectivity driverless cars you know tooth brushes which send out signal when you've got any more toothpaste
fridges which order in the milk when you've gotten off your cereal this is what what we're moving towards and all this is done wirelessly and it's done with radio frequency microwave radiation
but they don't call it that they call it smart and all this is filling your home with this invisible radiation which again thousands of studies are linking to a long list of serious diseases including cancer
so that fridges to the next step is what people can understand that two degree it's not that they have to become emf specialists but the biggest thing is people are going to say okay what do I have to do about it you mentioned
you know put your your smartphone in the other room would you go to bed or turn it off completely get it out of there put it in a fair day cage
put a cover on your router your Wi-Fi turn it off and I don't have your why don't use a Wi-Fi at home what are some practical steps that a person can take without having somebody come in their house and check all their EMFs and get it at EMF
so I'll give you three things I'd like to give you three things if I can first thing is I'll talk about the cell phone and then I'll talk about the Wi-Fi and then I'll talk about electricity because those are three areas which are impacting everybody
and these are three things which you can do which don't really cost any more a lot of this doesn't cost money so there are some higher end solutions but a lot of what you can do is free
so the first thing is with your cell phone it's how you use a cell phone because for many people this is a major source of EMF exposures are going oh my god the 5G it's arriving but they're walking around with their cell phones switched on the walking round using their cell phone like this
so that's the first recommendation don't put your cell phone next to your brain you want to talk about cancer well that's where the research is very strong linking cell phones to cancer brain cancer brain tumors
etsylateral tumors tumors on the same side of the head is your cell phone how curious is that
tumors where people are putting women putting cell phones in their bras tumors in exactly the same position as the cell phone in the bra
so cancer so with the cell phone it's it's using your again back to distance is your friend think about that when you think about EMF's distance is your friend putting maximum distance between you and the phone
that's what you need to do and when you're using it so how can you do that when you're using it well either you put it on speaker phone that's not always possible I know all you use what's called an air tube headset
an air tube headset that's it that's what you're using has a little bit of air tube in it as it says the name suggests in the wire which breaks the signal because otherwise that wire can attract
the ambient radiation in the room and beam it up to your brain and therefore actors and antenna basically and amplify this radiation effect that is already there in the environment
because as you know as we keep saying we're surrounded even though we can't see it most people can't feel it it doesn't mean you're not being impacted and again that's what the science says
very important point is that these exposures affect everybody it's not because you can't feel it that they're not impacting you your cells can feel it this is what the science is saying
so using an air tube headset using speaker phone using airplane mode as much as possible and avoiding using your cell phone in your car like a Friday cage it's a bit like the microwave oven we're talking about earlier
these are just some simple steps text don't talk don't go silly on the texting either we want to be using wide connections preferably and cell phones might be sexy and seductive
but they're dangerous they're using radio frequency microwave radiation that's why we should not be abusing of them particularly not our children
so that's the first thing very very quickly on cell phone second thing is with regard to Wi-Fi everybody's got Wi-Fi I know it's great I don't I never had because I got sick before the Wi-Fi arrived
so the Wi-Fi what I recommend first recommendation is just switch the Wi-Fi off at night who needs Wi-Fi when they're sleeping that's when your body is most vulnerable it's at night when your body heals it's when your cells regenerate rejuvenate detoxify
so you don't want to be exposing yourself to that radiation at night given everything we know about how these exposures impact our health notably impact the production of this very important hormone called melatonin
lot of research on that and if we want to take it further with the Wi-Fi so just unplugging it that's what I recommend
unplug this modem router as I say with my British accent unplug the modem router at night and if you want to go a step further for $10 buy one of those little mechanical timers you know like that idea came to me about 10 years ago you know like the Christmas tree timer
use one of them use great idea yeah like for burglars you know use one of those switching on and off rather than going in the settings and doing all that because soon as an upgrade then it will go back to default and you get the Wi-Fi again
and third thing so just to finish on the Wi-Fi to take this further then my recommendation is to go hard wired okay so wires aren't pretty but wires are really a superior form of communication and they're safe
and this is Wi-Fi G you know for the minute you know the 5 we can never do nearly as fast wirelessly despite what industry might be telling us as we can wired you know wired and fiber optics is doing way way faster way safer
and then thirdly so go go wide if you can ethernet replace the Wi-Fi with the wide internet connection and then thirdly just to go back to so there's one room which is the most important room in your home
sure you know well that is actually a bedroom and again we're back to the bedroom because it's not just an hour you know a place where you get some cap and some shots eye and it's just something you have to do no this is essentially it's a foundation it's a pillar of health sleep quality sleep
and you cannot get quality sleep if you're exposed to EMS 24 seven and there's all kinds of EMS in the average bedroom I can tell you there's magnetic there's the 4 kinds so there's 4 kinds of EMS there's a radio frequency radiation which we've been talking about right from the beginning which is 5G and the wireless and everything else
there's the electric fields so as soon as you've got wiring you've got electric fields whether you have something switched on or not you can be in total darkness but you're in an electric field you're sleeping in electric field
it's creating electrical tension in your body and the third kind is magnetic fields so if everything switched off you shouldn't be in a magnetic field unless maybe there's a wiring error which is very common also wiring errors extremely common up to 2 thirds of homes
have wiring errors and then fourthly is dirty electricity which boy I mean this is going to be a lot of people if they've never heard about this but our homes in our field with dirty electricity sounds evil and nastily is
and there are links again with this dirty electricity to cancer just that in itself I mean we've got a studies linking these exposing schools terrible with terrible outcomes
with these exposures of dirty electricity these frequencies which are on the electrical wiring which shouldn't be in fact and the problem is and you might be going well yeah but if it's on electrical wiring that's okay
because it's on the wire yeah well no it's it doesn't stay on the wire because most homes have Romex plastic coated wiring and it does not contain the EMFs okay unless you have special shielded wiring so most homes 90% of homes have got this ordinary wiring and this dirty electricity permeates out
so where I'm going with this third recommendation is to for a week if possible go to your breaker panel and switch off the electrical circuit for your bedroom now I'm not guaranteeing that this is going to solve all your problems make you feel better and instantly you know you'll sleep like a baby but try it because again because we can have imbalances in electrical system in your homes electrical wiring system
which can mean we can you can create more emfs and would have otherwise be the case so you try you know it was always you listen to your body socket and see and try it for seven days and if you find after seven days it's better then would look for more longer term solution which is like what I have which is an automated shot off at night and I just go to bed and there's no magnetic fields electric fields all dirty electricity
your power is completely shut up breaker panel to your bedroom at night it is so I use so I'm in Europe so and there's a company called gigahertz solutions which make which are out of Germany and they make like you know all the building biologists and people the top people are using the gigahertz solutions meters and I have a few
cheapy ones but I mean we've got high end meters you know in the thousands of dollars which they produce and they also produce these auto cutoffs which you need to get an electrician to install but in in the US so it just what happens with me is I got a bed and I switch the light out and it switches a circuit off and then if I want to go out for a pee in the middle of the night I can I just switch the light on and the
the circuit is reactivated by me switching the light on and it's so it's yeah it's and that is what I use with gigahertz solutions but it's a company called EMF so it's EMF sleep safe I believe they're called who manufacture these switches which are kind of plug-on player is for an electrician to do so you can't do it you know and just if you're good with electricity I don't recommend it get an electrician to do it but it's easy
to do easy to install you have a plethora of this information on your website so that data that you just discussed is that available at electrics.com of course so the point everybody to that will have data so that people can look at your website it's wonderful interviews I just want to say and great source of information they're out there
back to we just started this and there's so many people that out there in in the world that poo poo this until they end up with a serious disease and then they have to start really looking at causes and and realize that they're affected by this in a lot of things that we talk about people there's certain people that are much more negatively affected by EMFs that others some of it has to do with
a certain family of genes that if you have defects on you're going to be more affected some of it has to do a big part of it has to do if you have any inflammation in the brain and any microglial damage that's a certain type of cell in your brain
and that can be caused from concussion that can be caused from like an infection like Lyme disease anything that can cause an increase inflammation in the brain that person is going to be much more susceptible to the negative effects of EMFs but what we have said for a long time is that the rise of early dementia and Alzheimer disease
it's certainly tied to toxic exposure but you cannot eliminate the negative effects and the intuitive effects of toxins plus EMFs and how that's affected our brain because these EMFs are going right through our body they're going right through our brain there's nothing stopping them your skull is not protecting you
and what it's doing to neural tissue that has very little space for excess inflammation is just the right scary
Yes so just a bounce back on that one of the things which is very clear from the research and this is research dating back to the 1970s is that radio frequency microwave exposures
as used by cell phones and similar devices have the ability to damage the blood brain barrier and this is 1970s research which has been replicated over and over and over again
and the blood brain barrier is very important for keeping toxins out keeping nutrients in and once that barrier is damaged then there is possibly a whole load of consequences downstream from that in terms of medical outcomes in terms of symptoms in terms of what I call diseases and in terms of little diseases
so I don't think we can underestimate just that aspect of it and again there is a lot of science behind so one of the bits of science which is particularly clear is that which has been brought
which is the work by Dr Martin Paul on these voltage gated calcium channels which are all over our body in the cells and it's where there are concentrations of these voltage gated calcium channels what we know is that these calcium channels that the normal operation is is upset by these EMF exposures
calcium is leaking into the cells and everything that that means which is in a not shop premature aging and then possibly diseases and we have a concentration of these calcium channels in our brains
and so this is again another so there's lots of lots of different avenues lots of different ways that the EMFs are affecting us which the literature is showing really very clearly
yeah this scary thing is it's like you said it's not going to necessarily I mean in one sense I want to be careful say this it was a huge blessing that you got sick
not only did it move you towards your life's work here but most people won't experience that they'll end up with a disease down the road
like Alzheimer's disease in their 60s never never put the two things together that it was because of EMF exposure plus toxic exposure so they damaged the blood brain there your toxins could get into the brain
cause these glial cells damage and tangles and lead to the disease of Alzheimer's never putting the two things together
and the sad thing is that once you go down that road and you have damaged microglial cells many of those are not fixable even if you stop the EMF exposure and you get rid of the toxins
you can maybe slow the disease process at that point but now you can't correct it so be as proactive as possible in taking care of EMF exposure that you are not currently feeling is going to pay dividends down the road
and that's really what your site is about is educating people
it is you know I'm guessing the people are watching this well the perhaps people that have a story with cancer
and then there are just perhaps people that are health conscious and I see so many people that are supposedly health conscious
and you know they're working out and they're eating the right foods and they're putting all these expensive pills and potions into the body
and yet they're not there are completely overlooking this really basic toxin it's a killer you know these EMFs are a killer
and they're slowly killing you you know this is what again what the science is saying
and it's not just the EMFs obviously it's the EMFs with the other toxins and we've got studies on this also how the EMFs interact with other toxins
notably with heavy metals which there is obviously our bodies most people's bodies are saturated with heavy metals
unless you've done some specific detox then you know most people have got metal fillings
and the food that we eat most people eat you know a lot of people eat processed foods
which particularly in the US I know you know the soil is particularly heavy in these toxins
so it's this it's this synergistic effect the EMFs plus everything else which is and also it's not I mean it's you know the viruses
we're not getting to that but anyway the virus is the next it's so you know the mental the mental toxins the emotional toxins it's all of this and it's all working together
because you know when it happened to me I was living the dream you know we just moved to France with my wife and to start my own business
everything was going very well and then boom this came out of the blue and so but there were some other things going on
obviously in the background in my life which I wasn't aware of and it's so it's always EMFs and something else
it's never wanted it's really one toxin in isolation
well thank you so much for being in the podcast I'd love to have you on again we can talk about so many of these little pieces in detail
we're going to be pointing people to your website electricsense.com
are physically in France is that right that is correct it's great just so neat how we can connect worldwide
this is not a problem in one part of the world it's everywhere like you said satellites are beaming this down at us
it's something you can run but you really cannot hide there's certain things you could do to protect final note
yes so if I could I just wanted to say that I am actually putting on an online event which is free which is called the EMF House Summit
and it's from the 12th of July 12th to the 19th of July with over 40 experts on this question
we really go deep on the science and the solutions every single expert we talk about solutions so it's very solutions oriented
and so absolutely check that out perhaps we'll put that information up as well that's up on your website as well
it's on my website and yes we can send you a link on that which you can include on in the show notes
all right well thank you so much again Lloyd again this is Dr. Carter's thanks for being part of our podcast again today
thank you so much Dr. Connor thank you all right bye bye bye